c'est le client qui pourrait presque
faire partir les plats ici pas de
cloison ni de vitres le chef est à
portée de main le fait que ça soit au
vert non pas tout ce qui fait de voir
nos maux
ces prêts à la minute ces maisons
surtout mais aussi de toute réprimande
c'est un exercice qui a un peu compliqué
dans le sens où voilà on n'a pas le
droit à l'erreur dans la mise en place
mais sinon c'est vraiment très
intéressant et il ya vraiment ce moment
de partage vraiment qui se dégage de
cette expérience la table du chef est
privilégiée mais les autres ne sont pas
en reste et même au premier étage on
sait aussi servir par le chef ce qui est
pas courant dans les restaurants et puis
bon on peut demander quelles sont les
astuces du chef voilà moi gg j'ai
demandé notamment les ingrédients de la
petite sosa pour le burger donc voilà je
trouve que cette proximité est très
importante à l'origine du projet avec
alexandre deux autres associés dont l'un
a fait du concept de cuisine son métier
depuis qu'on avait créé ce concept on
savait qu'ils avaient beaucoup de gens
de la restauration qui sortait du métier
parce qu'il ya trop de contraintes donc
après forcément ça reste un métier ou de
commerce où on obligé de suivre les les
horaires des gens qui en profitent mais
ça n'empêche qu'on peut trouver son
modèle et c'est celle des c'est vraiment
tout le thème qu'on a voulu donner à ce
modèle de concept de trouver l'équilibré
entre la vie professionnelle et la vie
privée
car l'objectif est bien de créer une
franchise ici chef en centre val de
loire c'est d'associer aussi des
principes de consommation qui sont
modernes avec les copines on a vu
beaucoup de choses évoluer le emporté on
a vu la réservation en ligne le fait
d'être servis à table comparé à début
fait qu'on pouvait voir
traditionnellement fleurir de plus en
plus donc on va jouer on voit
aujourd'hui chercher tous ces nouveaux
modes de de consommation les nouvelles
allant très vite plusieurs grands noms